america has elected a new president
but what will the 46th
commander-in-chief do and what will joe
biden's america
look like
as joe biden moves into the white house
and becomes leader of the free world
he's taking over a deeply divided
country tackling a deadly virus
his pitch on the campaign trail was to
be a unifier
but that could be difficult to vote for
trump like true american
we've been getting middle finger stuff
thrown at us all for the past hour and a
half that we've been here
the most pressing issue on biden's
agenda is coped 19.
this is not political it's patriotic
wearing a mask
wear one period unlike his predecessor
he has pledged to listen to the
scientists if we're going to choose
science over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because we have enormous opportunities
enormous opportunities to make things
better his plan to combat covid
includes working with local leaders to
require americans to wear face masks
he also wants to expand testing and make
a vaccine free
for everyone
president biden needs to pull the us out
of an economic hole
and drive a global recovery hundreds of
thousands of americans
are still unable to find a job because
of the pandemic
biden's plan to invest government money
to restart the economy
has been compared to fdr's new deal
policies during the great depression
that's exactly what he did lifting us
out of a great depression
president guided not by wistful thinking
but by science reason and fact that's
the kind of present i hope to be
biden has promised to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars in u.s
industry provide loans to small
companies and
reverse some of donald trump's tax cuts
making wealthier americans
pay more he's also shown support for a
national minimum wage almost double what
it is now
that economic vision is tied up with his
desire to put america back at the
forefront of the fight against
climate change we can make sure that our
economy
is being run and moved and motivated by
clean energy creating millions of new
jobs
biden wants to spend two trillion
dollars on clean energy
like solar and wind technologies he's
also set an ambitious target of net
zero carbon emissions by 2050
and he wants the us to rejoin the paris
climate accord
which president trump abandoned in
support of the fossil fuel industry
[Music]
while donald trump carved a path as an
outlier on the international stage
joe biden is more likely to embrace the
institutions that trump
demonized like nato and the world health
organization
biden also wants america to once again
be a player in the iran
nuclear deal alongside european allies
and don't expect more love letters to
dictators
you know what north korea we're not in a
war we have a good relationship
you know people understand having a good
relationship with leaders of other
countries
we had a good relationship with hitler
before he in fact invaded
europe the rest of europe come on the
british government will be scrambling to
talk to the new administration about a
post-brexit trade deal
the us is britain's biggest trading
partner after the eu
and while biden respects the us uk
special relationship
he'll also see relations with europe as
a priority
back on the home front biden will be
judged heavily on the way he deals with
racial tensions
he's already faced criticism for his
record on race
over more than three decades as a u.s
senator
but amidst national protests over police
brutality
and inherent racism biden the candidate
promised biden the president
would make equality a priority
this is joe biden black lives matter
period i'm not afraid to say it
he's promised to invest in and lend to
black and brown businesses
and increase access to affordable
housing for minority communities
many americans struggle to pay for
medical care and
insurance plans are pricey donald trump
repeatedly tried to dismantle
obamacare and in doing so drastically
reduce
the number of people with medical
insurance joe biden wants to expand his
old bosses program
to cover more americans and we have now
just enshrined
as soon as i signed this bill the core
principle
that everybody should have some basic
security
when it comes to their help
president biden's policies and his picks
for cabinet
will have to tread a careful line far
enough to the left
to please the democrats increasingly
liberal base
but he can't alienate the centrist
voters that secured him this victory
and risk losing a second term it ain't
over man we're just getting started
at 78 biden becomes america's oldest
president and some are skeptical about
him running again
in 2024 would his vice president kamala
harris
take his place whoever is on the ticket
in four years time they'll be running on
biden's achievements
or against his failures and america will
have to decide
whether he delivered